die woche der entscheidung die korona
zahlen explodieren die stiko die
ständige impfkommission will jetzt
booster impfungen bereits ab 18 jahren
empfehlen statt nur für über 70-jährige
und gesundheitsminister sparen sagt man
müsse auch nicht zwingend sechs monate
zwischen zweit und dritt impfung
vergehen lassen ja und morgen treffen
sich die ministerpräsidenten der länder
mit der bundesregierung und da geht es
vor allem um die frage welche
einschränkungen und drohen aufschluss
darüber gibt ein geheimpapier der
unions-ministerpräsidenten fit ob ist
bei uns im studio du hast exklusiv
dieses papier was steht denn drin
zwischen den chefs der staatskanzleien
also die staatskanzleien der
bundesländer haben sich zusammen
geschaltet in einer konferenz mit dem
kanzleramt um den corona gipfel
vorzubereiten und da gibt es folgende
wichtige punkte erstens der großteil der
unionsländer ist eigentlich für die
verlängerung der epidemischen notlage
also dieser rechtlichen notlage die auch
londons möglich macht die wissen aber
dass sie das nicht durchsetzen
fünfundzwanzigster männer läuft diese
aus ganz genau das einzige unions land
das sagt nee wir können die auslaufen
lassen ist schleswig holstein weil dort
die instanzen relativ niedrig sind die
haben die lage auch so im griff sagen
sie dann zweiter wichtiger punkt man
sucht einen neuen super coroner
richtwert und da gibt es bislang noch
keine einigung wer hat mir bislang die
sieben tage incidents mittlerweile weiß
man die ist auch nicht so viel wert in
deutschland hat sich komplett entkoppelt
von dem was wirklich in den kliniken los
ist das sagen zumindest die bundesländer
deswegen wollen sie auf die
hospitalisierung schauen diese debatten
hatten wir übrigens alle schon vor
monaten man weiß aber mittlerweile die
hospitalisierung incidents die das rkw
meldet die kommt teilweise zwei drei
vier wochen zu spät wirklich an also man
weiß erst mit einem monat einen monat
verspätung was wirklich in den
krankenhäusern los ist deswegen will das
kanzleramt weiter in der sieben tage des
instituts also nur auf die infektion
schauen da gibt es also noch keine
einigung was aber viele menschen
interessieren wird ist die eine
obergrenze für großveranstaltungen und
zwar sogar für 2g veranstaltungen also
auch wenn er vor einer veranstaltung nur
geimpfte und nur genesene sind soll es
dort eine obergrenze geben und da kam
die länder wirklich ins pöbeln und haben
gesagt unsere maßnahmen dürfen nicht so
wirken als würden sie sich vor allem
gegen geimpfte richten man fürchtet
nämlich den eindruck zu erwecken dass
der impfstoff dass die impfung nichts
bringen deswegen dass es besonders
spannend man sagt es dürfe keine
situation beschrieben werden die
irgendwie einen login für geimpfte
erinnere also es geht nicht nur um
konkrete maßnahmen sondern noch ganz
viele um kommunikation man möchte fast
schon sagen um propaganda aber wir
werden das im beschluss sehen es wird
auf jeden fall sehr sehr klar versucht
werden davon abzulenken dass auch
gamestar eingeschränkt werden man will
sich vor allem auf die umkämpften
konzentrieren uns wohl in den maßnahmen
als auch zwischen ihnen ein papier der
union hast du gesagt das heißt es geht
hier um die cdu geführten bundesländern
wie wird es bei der spd seien bei diesen
bund länder treffen gibt es da
übereinstimmung geben oder wird das eine
endlos sitzung bei der man zu keinem
ergebnis kommt so gewiss ja oft schon
gesehen haben tja also bislang haben sie
sich die länder eigentlich ganz gut
angenähert die unions länder haben ja
zum beispiel von der ampel gefordert
dass auch kontakt beschränkungen möglich
sein sollen das 3g am arbeitsplatz kommt
all das hat die ampel jetzt möglich
gemacht deswegen sind eigentlich keine
großen zoff punkte zu erwarten
eigentlich weil wir wissen ja alle wie
das ist plötzlich kommt am abend die
beschlussvorlage am vorabend des gipfels
also wahrscheinlich heute abend und da
steht irgend etwas drin womit fast
niemand gerechnet hat was das kanzleramt
zum beispiel noch selbst rein
geschrieben hat weil die kanzlerin ja
gestern auch mit den ministerpräsidenten
vor konferiert hat und da gesagt hat wir
stehen so schlecht da wie noch nie und
wenn das tatsächlich stimmt dass wir so
schlecht dastehen wie noch nie dann
bräuchte es vielleicht doch noch
schärfere maßnahmen so könnte es
zumindest das kanzleramt sehen und dann
haben wir eine völlig neue lage viele
menschen da draußen schauen natürlich
auch mit spannung morgen auf diese
konferenz weil weihnachten steht vor der
tür viele weihnachtsmärkte werden jetzt
auch grad schon wieder abgesagt
weihnachtsfeiern im übrigen auch haben
diesen das mit weihnachten zu hause
werden da einschränkungen erwartet also
es kann sein dass es zur einschränkung
für ungeimpfte menschen kommt kontakt
beschränkungen sollen ja jetzt möglich
sein das hat das mit die ampel jetzt ins
gesetz schreiben und nach schärfe das
also jedes bundesland für seine bürger
kontakt beschränkungen erlassen kann und
da könnte es zu einer situation kommen
die auch im vergangenen jahr erinnert
dass man sagt es dürften sich
beispielsweise nicht mehr als zehn
menschen oder zwei haushalte oder wie
auch immer zusammentreffen und dann
betrifft das natürlich auch sämtliche
war 2